Let's uh let's I I was waiting to jump
to this story so this one is uh this is
a sad tale a sad tale from our good
friend Hank Green now if you don't know
Hank Green he's one of the OG YouTubers
and uh he tweeted this which universe is
the better one one with humans one
without humans well I voted for the one
with humans because I'm human and I live
here but uh 41.1 said one without humans
he responded
I keep trying to do other versions of
this poll thinking that there's
something wrong with the question but it
I but it really does seem like 40
percent of you think humans shouldn't
exist and I find that so deeply outside
of my perspective that I need to do a
lot of thinking
he then added uh a little bit later I
feel like if an AI was like quote I'm 40
sure the universe without humans would
be better we'd be pretty worried
here's the funny thing these people
don't get it people like Hank Green he's
a default liberal he's surrounded by
default liberals and leftists they hate
human beings So you you're just
mentioning it earlier that it seems like
uh you know a lot of their policies are
actually just to harm you and I was
mentioning something similar yeah if
you've got here's the easiest way to
explain it
Hank Green's audience probably swinging
much more left he's like a VidCon guy
he's a major mainstream personality with
you know so liberals probably follow him
80 90 percent
if you're a Democrat politician and you
see a poll like this you know what that
means you're going to cater to the
people who don't like human beings so
you're out there campaigning and you're
like look
half of these people are really
concerned about their right to abortion
because they have a lot of loose sex a
lot of men and they want to be able to
get abortions if they get pregnant fine
the other half just don't want humans to
be alive anymore same solution to both
problems certainly then the Democrats
are going to advocate for that
it's a lot of the same people who have
been consuming a lot of nihilistic
propaganda on social media for years
about climate change every type of human
invention that's ever been created uh is
destroying the environment everything
we've ever done and succeeded is in some
way been reframed as a negative for The
Human Experience and I actually what you
were talking about earlier about social
media and how they will sometimes mess
with the algorithm I get that on Sundays
I sort it on Instagram Sundays become
the most nihilistic place ever on
Instagram it's nothing but the world is
going to end in 10 years manufacturing
is destroying the world and it's awesome
and they consume that content all the
time and they've been led to believe
that this type of hatred of humanity
isn't just good but something to be
valorized and you know what they do they
complain about how there's like a great
Extinction phase happening and how
humans are the human actions are killing
off all of these different forms of life
but they never stop to talk about the
the strange scientific experiments we're
doing to bring life back like trying to
clone a woolly mamas or calling ancient
viruses out of the ice sheets and
resurrecting them great ideas these are
all great ideas that humans are humans
are doing actually when people saw that
stuff during covert they're like maybe
you shouldn't maybe you should just not
bring stuff out of the ice caps until we
know for sure it's going to hurt but but
uh simply but it really does feel like
you know everyone's always trying to
figure out what the Divide is like I've
seen people say it's nationalist versus
globalist and it's like as a component
of that and I think it's algorithmic
cult versus independent thought but
there is a component of humans are good
and humans are bad there's a component
of you know God God is real and there is
no God and if you're a nihilist and you
think nothing matters there's no
morality and everything is subjective
why would you want humans to be around
at all it's like uh Dr Manhattan in
Watchman when he was like on Mars and
he's like would any of this be made
better by humans and the answer is yes
it would be I mean at least from a human
perspective because that's what we are
and that's what we strive for the
feelings and experiences of Being Human
I mean I don't know I was watching this
little bird building nest the other day
and I'm like I wonder what bird Society
must be like do you think they're like
you know life is good life is bad you
get depressed
I think a lot of this for a lot of the
best way to describe this for me the
best experience that I've had knowing
that people are very nihilistic right
now is when we had sunshine in like uh
January or February it was like really
nice out and people like well it's
because of climate change but we might
as well enjoy it while we're here yeah I
mean it didn't snow uh no we got like
none this year none and I was talking to
some old guy and he's like that's the
first night he's like 60 years old he's
like it's the first time in my life I
didn't get any snow yeah and I'm like oh
that's kind of crazy but of course
the issue is not so much about whether
or not there's snow it's about whether
or not humans are the direct impact and
so you know what I see are causing the
the crisis what I see with the left is
like
one without humans
what would this planet be without humans
it would just be a moist a moist ball of
rust some kind of exotic rust on it
oxidization process and you know these
people that vote to say that the world
would be better without humans are the
exact same people with the exact same
mentality about America they live in
America as if they have to be and then
they're so anti-American they're always
saying that they want to see the
downfall of America but where is better
yeah why is it that you see they never
actually give you an answer not usually
no it's parts of it's parts of places
that exist they wanted they want us like
an A La Carte Society where they can say
this is good in this place this is good
in this place this is good in this place
so let's take all these things and bring
them here and they imagine that they can
just manufacture the society if they
just say well these are the things that
we want we'll just bring them here and
and and act it's as if the people that
are involved don't matter at all and it
it's the the blank slate applied to
societies like societies have cultures
how societies have history so societies
have different values from one Society
to another so you can't just replicate
the the good things about one Society in
your Society without without having some
kind of negative consequences or or
unforeseen consequences at least so
I think that it's a lot of a lot of the
idea that it it is as simple as just
well that works over there so how come
it doesn't work over here it was the
same mistake that we made when we went
to Iraq the idea that we could just
Implement democracy in in Iraq like oh
just get rid of the get rid of the
strong arm guy and and we'll make a
democracy and it'll work fine and that's
not the way that people work the cia's
been doing that for years
democracy all over the place I'm working
awesome
it's also the but the a lot of Americans
what I've noticed and this was long
before I became politically aware hate
this cut like seem to have a if not a
hatred of this country they're
embarrassed to be from here and I never
understood it it's really simple is the
glass half full or is the glass half
empty you know are you are you excited
that there is water in your water bottle
or are you like angry because it's half
gone the glass is racist I'm just right
that I can drink the water here but this
is this is this is like I guess the
thing maybe like the real divide may be
optimism versus pessimism if you look at
the history of the United States you can
look at it a bunch of different ways you
can be honest and say there's a lot of
really awful stuff and a lot of really
good stuff or uh you can be angry and
just say this country is bad no matter
what it's all bad period it's born of
bad it's bad it's bad that's stupid and
that's depressive so I these people are
nihilistic half of them probably just
want to burn everything down because
they hate humans the other half refuse
to seek out the good because there's
something wrong with them I guess you
know I look back at American history and
if someone comes to me and says do you
know what the Americans did to the
Native Americans and you know in this
place in that place and I'll be like oh
yeah I write about that that's awful I
can't believe they would do that and
then it's like do you also know about
the good things this country has done
over the past several hundred years as
we've dramatically improved upon all of
those things and got to the point where
you have now been educated in publicly
funded institutions explaining we think
those are bad things yeah think about
the the college student who's like
America is awful and racist I learned
that at a publicly funded University the
government's paying you so you can learn
about how we don't like those things
anymore and they still think this
country is a problem
I think the end result is just
the left will cease to exist you know
they try to undocument your kids the
only thing they can do but it's not
gonna it's not working uh and then the
right is going to just have a bunch of
babies and then 20 years you know there
we go you don't think it's working
what like the education stuff I'm saying
that you don't think that the
indoctrination from the left is working
in my eyes it's not working you don't
think so uh why like so for one shows
like this we consistently have like the
highest live viewer count on YouTube
which is a good sign you can see like
the Budweiser backlash The View being
desperate obviously there is let us
indoctrination it is very strong but I'm
speaking specifically in refer referring
to kids it is in my opinion not working
okay so uh simply put when parents
realize what's happening at their
schools start pulling their kids out
when there is now a national
conversation around school choice and
getting kids out of public schools and
moving away from these places it didn't
work and what I mean ultimately is
I think conservatives are gonna have
more kids
those kids are more likely to be
conservative they're they're going to
learn from their parents the parents are
waking up not all of them but many of
them are waking up to what's going on in
schools the left is beginning to fail
with places like Florida and other
states reforming these laws and banning
the stuff it may lead to
hyperpolarization but ultimately if
you're advocating if there if there were
two countries
and they were at odds with each other
and on one side they were saying have
more babies have more babies discipline
yourself strengthen yourself Eat Right
exercise and the other country was
saying be as fat as you want abort your
children and sterilize them
would there be any question to which
country would cease to exist in 20 years
none whatsoever so just because we are
the United States doesn't mean to me
that there is a mesh here clearly the
hyperpolarization is so pronounced that
the left and the right are are at such
fundamental odds that they may as well
be two different countries the point
where people are advocating for National
divorce and then what do you see
give it a long enough over long enough
period of time math is just math people
who don't have kids tend not to exist in
several Generations people who have kids
tend to pass on their ideas then you got
to get those kids out of call out of our
state-run colleges because I think we
can raise all the conservative kids we
want but if we send them to Public
Schools where they will later be
indoctrinated further into those
ideologies I don't know if it matters I
think you have to start at the
elementary you know at the school level
and then all the way up to colleges you
have to reform and not allow those kids
to be constantly flooded with the same
type of propaganda that we're seeing now
but I but I think we're we're moving in
that direction I think the left I I
everybody likes to talk about
um I shouldn't say everybody but they're
prominent individuals talking about
universities and the leftist ideology
and how it spread and all that but it
was never that strong until 2011 2012. I
think it's when social media algorithms
it was 2008 it was never that strong in
the U.S until so well not around the
world social media algorithms made every
country on the planet basically see this
massive spike in these conversations
however I think that was bad for them I
think if they had maintained the quiet
Edge and slow rolled this ideology over
a long period of time they'd have won
instead the algorithms slapped everybody
in the face with the most insane
versions of these ideologies that now
people are pushing back on it
universities are starting to get heat
because of it and people are
hyperpolarizing yeah I agree with that I
think for a while the left was starting
to win with their indoctrination but the
pendulum is starting to shift back over
to the right because what's happening is
the left continues to get more radical
they're going further and further right
while the right is just sitting left
left sorry yeah the left is getting
further and further left and the right
is just sitting there just trying to be
sane and I always tell people if you
want to help influence people to do more
research or to maybe reconsider their
mentality you don't even have to go deep
into like policies and politics just
talk about the cult culture like have
you seen the things with these naked
education shows or yeah there's all
these shows where they're getting naked
in front of children there is no sane
person in existence that's going to look
at that and not think that it's foul so
when you present that and you're like
well guess which side supports this and
it's all for this they start to question
their own let me spread around as much
as possible as many parents to see that
kind of stuff as possible thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time